[Musique]
comme chaque mardi mélanie pocket avec
moi en plateau bonsoir ça pour votre
coup de coeur vous avez choisi de parler
d'une oeuvre collaborative une pièce de
théâtre à découvrir en fin de semaine eh
oui qui mieux que les manifs quoi
pouvait parler de magny les hameaux
dix d'entre eux ont répondu à l'appel de
la compagnie à 7 septembre il participa
j'habite à manille c'est le titre du
spectacle à l'origine de l'idée metteur
en scène catherine l'aisne les
participants font des mini quads donc
deux plusieurs générations de plusieurs
quartiers de la ville et y témoigne la
partir de là on essaie de composer un
spectacle à partir des anecdotes à
partir de leurs ressentis à partir de
leurs émotions à partir de leur vécu
d'habitants et ils nous décrivent la
ville je leur demande par exemple de
décrire ce qu'il se passe par leur
fenêtre ce qu'ils voient comment par
exemple aussi si il se balade dans leur
ville s'ils vont dans les autres
quartiers
qu'est ce qu'ils y font dans leur ville
et ses manies qu elles seront sur scène
le 18 mai pour présenter cette création
qui représente un long travail
ils réfléchissent à tout ça depuis le
mois de novembre se retrouvant une fois
par mois environ
catherine l'aisne a à chaque fois
récupéré les textes pour les assembler
les couper de temps en temps mais
c'était aussi pour les apprenties
comédiennes un autre travail savoir se
détacher de son texte
entrée sur scène un petit mot de deux
d'entre eux je raconte d'abord comment
je suis arrivé à manille par mes parents
et après je raconte des anecdotes des
souvenirs et je défends aussi pas mal
manie comme quoi c'est l'idée de la
ville à la campagne qu'on peut
ils vivre aussi bien que dans une
banlieue proche de paris
moi j'y raconte donc pourquoi j'ai eu
pourquoi je n'eus y vivre comment ça
s'est passé et puis aussi je raconte des
petites anecdotes dont une une anecdote
sur le sur le maire de magny les hameaux
alors une projection de photos de magny
les hameaux va compléter la
représentation pour découvrir la ville
autrement les comédiens seront sur la
scène de la maison de l'environnement
le samedi 18 mai à 20 heures merci
mélanie on vous retrouve dans un instant
à la présentation du 7-8 culture vous
parlerez notamment de la nuit des musées
et je crois du tremplin première scène
qui est organisé par le festival rock en
seine